controversy tonight surrounding some of
the dramatic media declarations in the
wake of the general Flynn out stir a
column in the New York Times put it on
par with some of the most devastating
attacks in our nation reading in part
quote we were attacked on December 7th
1941 we were attacked on September 11th
2001 and we were attacked on November
8th 2016 dan Rather out of this
Watergate is the biggest political
scandal of my lifetime until maybe now
and finally this from Chuck Todd one of
what is arguably the biggest
presidential scandal involving a foreign
government since iran-contra take a
breath hyperbole aside folks hunker down
because this is a class-five political
hurricane that's hitting Washington all
a class-five political hurricane Ben
Shapiro editor-in-chief of The Daily
wire calm and Richard Fowler nationally
syndicated radio host and Fox News
contributor gentlemen I hope you're
hunkered down because this is big big
Big Ben what do you what do you make of
all that I mean everybody sounds like a
used car salesman trying to hawk an old
Chevy Wow it's the level of the level of
outrage over something that we don't
even know what happened yet I mean I'm
still confused as to what Flynn did that
was supposed to be the worst thing that
ever happened since the biblical plagues
in between Thomas Friedman who
apparently has the brainpower of an
overused hairdryer and and Dan Rather
the godfather of modern media fake news
talking about how this is the greatest
crisis that we've ever seen in modern
political history again what happened
that's it's very simple do we should we
know what happened before we start to
freak out lose our minds yeah I mean
it's an excellent question Richard when
you're dig into the New York Times piece
today which you know started off
declaring that there had been so much
contact between the Trump campaign and
Russia that it was just you know sort of
it's so dramatic in the nature of it
that they just had to dig and dig and
then it said but we dug and dug and so
far we haven't found anything at all in
terms of a nefarious connection they may
but we don't know that yet I mean Martha
you're right we don't know we don't know
that there is a Christ I think the media
is being a little rough on the Trump
stir but here's why I think the reason
why the media is being so rough on the
Trump stir has everything to do with the
fact that they could they've circled the
wagons
haven't released any information a
little bit of ice for the Donald if he's
watching tonight right the first thing
you do is you release these transcripts
of the Intelligence Committee they'll
get it classified get it over with so
you could move on
he's gonna need political capital
argument was used for Hillary Clinton
yeah and it's it's the right argument
just get it all out there right because
a member he's got any political capital
to roll out infrastructure package isn't
any political capital to roll out his
tax reforms and right now ninety percent
Republicans like him but if this drip
drip drip continues Martha it could say
it could see it could create doom for
the Trump administration just 30 days in
yeah 27 days but up these headlines that
we have because this story really broke
a month ago it was out there you know
intercepted Russian communication part
of inquiry into Trump associates and
that story back then and a Washington
Post story back then as well said that
they didn't find anything nefarious they
didn't find any connection between these
communications and the election they
just found no that there was phone calls
and there was contact that they were
concerned about we know Sally Yates
brought that to the attention of the
White House as well and then I want to
remind everyone of this moment with
President Obama
a while back watch this
[Music]
I understand so after the election we
might be able to talk about that issue
that's bothering you is that essentially
what we think general Flynn may have
said Ben I think that's basically the
idea the only difference being that
President Obama was in the middle of an
election cycle and fluent apparently
said a lot of these things after the
election cycle was over it was like
three weeks before he was appointed and
I say Richard you're giving a lot of
advice to to Donald Trump I agree with a
lot of the advice that you're suggesting
for the Trump administration but some
advice for the media guys if you want
people to take you seriously you have to
stop setting your hair on fire and
running into play class windows before
you even know what the hell is going on
I mean you are jumping on every rake and
a 300 mile radius
before you even let all the facts out we
can't take you seriously unless you lay
out a series of facts that we can
believe instead of blowing up headlight
like the headline on that New York Times
piece could easily have been studies
show investigation shows no casual links
between Trump campaign and Russians I'm
going you know when you step on a rake
it can hit you in the head
yeah so once you've laid down these
markers that this is Watergate this is
Pearl Harbor this is 9/11 you better be
very careful what you put out there I
think that has everything to do with
Martha the fact that Donald Trump has
sort of take he's made the media enemy
right you go out there and your press
conference and say well yeah Mike Flynn
didn't resign which really did happen he
didn't accept present issues really to
happen and say I blame this all on fake
news what you begin to do is you put the
media's best reactions of listen here's
all the news here's all the facts as
they're being leaked out and I think
Donnell should be more concerned about
leakers in the White House them
throughout the government and he could
be she be concerned about the media and
quote/unquote fake news
all right good points all around thank
you very much gentlemen good to see you
tonight
good to see you Martha so